yo I hope you got your coffee ready
because this video is for you guys it's
a video request a lot of you guys ask me
and say hey Daniel I want to gain some
muscle but I'm not sure what kind of
white protein is the best to help me
with it so in this video I'm gonna cover
the five best whey proteins for muscle
gain so let's not waste any more time
let's get right into the video
[Music]
mistakes mistakes make you strong if
you're new here to my channel welcome
I'm Daniel
consider subscribing and also clicking
the notification valve so you won't miss
any of the next videos now most of my
subscribers know already that I travel
as an international male model now when
I need to travel from one country to
another sometimes I need to lose weight
very fast or pick up weight very fast so
meaning gaining muscle for example in
Japan they want me to be skinny so my
chest is around 96 and then in South
Africa they want me to be bigger right
like a fitness model so then my chest is
around 103 so it's very different and I
need to gain or lose that weight pretty
fast because as soon as I'm in that
market I need to be able to fit their
clothes to get jobs and to pay the bills
and I always do this by having the right
diet plan and workout routine and very
important they're right whey protein now
there's a lot of good whey proteins out
there and there's some that's like not
so good but in this video we're only
gonna cover the top 5 whey protein so
let's start with the first one
first on the list is optimum nutrition
gold standard they've been around for a
very long time and they're a trusted
brand across the world most guys have
use it get very good results but don't
just take my word for it check out the
customer reviews on it I'll add a clean
in a video description as always so you
can go ahead and check it out
it offers white protein isolates which
is the purest form of protein that you
can get you get 24 grams of 100% white
protein per serving 5.5 of BCAAs 4 grams
of glutamine and precursors for optimum
muscle repair and growth and just 120
calories check it out in the video
description so you can do your own
research as well let's move on to the
next one
[Music]
now if you're very skinny and you
struggle to gain muscle because you've
been blessed with a very fast metabolism
then you cannot just rely on white
protein itself you need a very good
quality diet nutrition plan where you
get enough high quality healthy carbs
that will really help you to gain the
weight that you need but with that being
said this isn't video only on the whey
protein so the next one is stack protein
powder from evolution nutrition he's got
25 grams of protein 6 grams of BCAAs
and 5 grams of glutamine per serving
with zero sugar
he's got fast and slow release protein
and is gluten free MuscleTech nitro tech
this is a personal favourite because I
always experience fantastic results
whenever I use it it's perfect to gain
more muscle more strength and better
performance for one serving you get
three grams of mostly whey protein
isolate and whey peptides 6.8 grams of
BCAA aminos 5 gram of glutamine and
precursor and it also has a three gram
dose of HPLC tested creatine monohydrate
and it also tastes really good
now there's also a lot of vegans out
there and I didn't forget about you you
can check out naked pee which is 100%
premium P protein there's zero additives
so you don't need to worry about any
sneaky kind of artificial sweeteners or
flavors or GMOs per serving you get 27
grams of protein 5.7 grams of BCAAs 120
calories 2 grams of carbs and 2 grams of
sugar
now if you want the best natural protein
then you can try a hundred percent
grass-fed New Zealand whey protein
isolate it's from antler farms and he
gets zero hormones no antibiotics no
chemicals and no GMOs it gives you more
protein than other options plus they use
natural organic vanilla and stevia leaf
extract for the taste now per serving
you get 26 grams of protein 160 grams of
calories and one gram of fat now just
some last advice remember that whatever
supplement you go with that fits in with
your lifestyle you need to use it with a
good consistent nutritional plan and
workout routine if you're not sure where
to start check out a video description
I've added some really good videos that
will really help you out and give you a
kind of guide you like the video give it
a thumbs up subscribe and I'll see you
in the next video